[Music]
some of the small things that I love
about Wonka is just this analyzed
beautiful the best the world life
[Music]
I love being in the voice I love our
life conformation
[Music]
in the symbol Society it's difficult for
women to be away from their family
there's a pride there's a big pride
although it's it separates sometimes
sometimes so it's a huge pride
hopefully we like the first time I saw a
lion in the world it was extraordinary
[Music]
the last time I saw so the lion was in
2015 I knew very well because he was one
of my study lions he had a collar and
were tracking him and I was collecting
data with the Cubs I didn't expect that
to be the last time that I'll see I'd
say it was the last time that I saw you
killed a 13 year old lion and tourist
attraction in Zimbabwe safari industry
special was perhaps Zimbabwe most famous
lion the majestic male 13 years old with
the famous black mane has been killed by
hunters I think it's important to have
some good come out of this disgusting
tragedy so this is the website for the
wildlife conservation research unit unit
at Oxford wild sea are you
[Music]
it opens many people's eyes to learn
conservation issues and it also helped
me to cover my fourth year of PhD at
Oxford University I was at home in
Kimberley when I had that is all was
shot
I live in Kim believed was my family's
there it's a small town in the northern
cape and South Africa it's complicated
because I live in three countries I'm
living in Kimberley at the moment with
my family but I'm also studying in
Oxford in the UK and I also spent some
time in the field in animation effect
where I'm studying lions I have to find
a balance between my work in the
National Park and my son
[Music]
it has been a process for him to
understand you know when he was little
it was difficult for him every time I
went away but as improve order is now
more understanding of the situation the
past right from Kampala South Africa to
one National Park is very long right it
takes more than 36 hours I wake up at 6
o clock in the morning and get to the
bus the bus will take me to join spread
in South Africa in John spec is it
frightens me to be there and it's not
safe so I change buses and take another
pass that means with me in LA oil' in
Zimbabwe and at the border it may take
hours for for the bus to be processed
and for us to reprocess the bus from
blower to engage it's unpredictable
sometimes it's late and it's not a large
and college so it's not comfortable at
all and sometimes it's parent
[Music]
it's always exciting to see the land it
always feels like the first time so I'm
always excited when I feel the like oh
yeah I think in order for us to to come
up with conservation measures we have to
understand how especially health so we
record how many individuals they are
their sex their age and whether they
belong to that pride or their new
individuals for females some of the data
collecting is very abundant data to stop
you can tell me to stop when you see
something okay
are we driving and recording no one was
our try it out we sitting in front of
the vehicle on a specialized it counting
all the animal track ceases we collect
data on all the animal species that we
find you know there's this where the
hero say she is risky because we do a
lot of walking even like when you are
driving this always a risk of
encountering elephants between lions and
buffaloes so it's always risky
all the prefer work with our wonderful
sometimes difficult to be the only woman
among all the men but they treat me as
an equal and they expect me as a person
and I think that's why we work together
very well it would be easier to go and
wake in another country and be a
scientist someone else it's so default
to her to survive in Zimbabwe the
economy is collapsing and so it is
really difficult to get by but I would
want to stay in Zimbabwe and health
field Zimbabwe it was there the future
will be brighter it's all waited they
have things that I boiled they think
that I love I love my son and I love my
job
have you thought about giving up
[Music]
there are moments when I have thought
about giving out it had been all men in
science society doesn't remain the same
way they treat men it's not acceptable
for me to be away or to travel a lot but
we're men to do the same thing it's
acceptable but it's something that I
love and so I have to find a way to move
forward
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]